- Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich suche Lisa Brunner.
- Entschuldigung, wen suchen Sie?
- Lisa Brunner.
- Hallo, Max Stöpel mein Name.
Wir suchen eine Lisa Brunner.
Sie hat hier um 14 Uhr
ein Bewerbungsgespräch.
- Also, die Bewerbungsgespräche finden
normalerweise im Besprechungsraum statt.
- Wo, wo, ey ey ey,
wo finden wir den Besprechungsraum?
- In der dritten Etage.
Aber, nein, warten Sie!
Ich glaube, heute finden
die Bewerbungsgespräche
in der vierten Etage
neben der Kantine statt.
- Aha.
- Sie nehmen den Aufzug,
fahren in die vierte Etage.
Da gehen Sie links, dann rechts
und wieder links.
Der Besprechungsraum ist rechts.
Zimmer 431.
- 431. Vielen Dank!
- 431, 431, wo ist die 431?
- Da, ein Lageplan!
Wir sind hier, neben den Toiletten.
- Da. Zwischen den …
- … Konferenzräumen.
Da lang!
- Nein, da lang!
Lisa!
- Du hast deine
Bewerbungsunterlagen vergessen.
- Oh, mein Gott! Ihr seid meine Retter!
Danke, danke, danke, danke!